No. Nobody love Christmas, Carol. Yeah. I love the holidays.
I love eggnog missile toes. No, I can make it to the company's holiday party.
Your sample isn't taken a day off. Neither am I?
No, not you Holly.
So you just moved in
the box. Oh yeah. Good catch.
Well known for having a good. I see you when you're sleeping, Santa.
Okay.
Pay me. I won't be on the last Christmas after. No,
not you Carol. Sorry. I got a little distracted.
I'm at the sky and Oh yeah. I'll just come in. Yeah. Good idea.
No problem. So PFS.
Do you have any exposition you want to tell me maybe about a little
distraction, Carol. I just met the cutest boy in the hallway.
We bumped into each other and he just moved in the building. Oh really?
I think he may have broken my nose. So, uh, Oh. Oh, well that's nothing.
A little Christmas cheer. Can't fix so true. Oh my gosh.
The study of ever Christmas party in the bathroom.
[inaudible] these numbers.
[inaudible] I'll get it.
Nick. The terrible music you're listening to is distracting me from my work.
There's no way you think Christmas music is terrible. The perfect guy,
10 minutes ago.
One of those Christmas loving people, huh?
Everyone loves Christmas. Nick,
do you not love Christmas?
Do Nick, do you love Christmas, Holly?
Not only do I not love it?
I don't like it.
Sorry girl. No, no.
Carol. I'm not giving up that easily.
I'm going to get that Scrooge into the Christmas spirit.
If it's the last thing I do, you need my help, Carol.
You're my BFF. The only thing I need from you are sassy. Affirmations.
You all have that boy breath on your Christmas tree by morning. Perfect.
Thanks.
Listen, Bob, the presentation is not going to present it.
No, this is Miami.
How many times do I have to tell her? I don't like Christmas.
Are you seriously eating this? Let me cook for you.
But I promise I won't talk about Christmas.
This is so good. What do you do exactly?
Well, when I was a kid,
I used to pray every night for white Christmas in Miami,
but then I grew up and I realized if Santa couldn't do it, I could.
So I started this business and now I travel around people's houses and I mean,
it's not outside their windows. Oh.
And I even have a secret family recipe that makes us know, look extra.
What's the recipe. It's a family secret. You and family.
Are you Nick? It's ready?
This is amazing. All right, Nick,
why do you hate Christmas so much?
What happened? Something happened in prison.
Tell me Nick.
I think we'll wait till after the commercial break. If you don't mind. Oh yeah.
Fine.
Nick. What happened
Nick? Oh yeah. Um,
my wife died a gruesome death on Christmas and
come over.
The bronc parent died that day. Oh, she's adorable, man.
We don't celebrate Christmas. He sad. Maybe it's time.
That changed holiday Christmas montage.
[inaudible]
no for somebody who's not too into Christmas or stockings. Pretty well home.
If you think why stocking so well hung, you should see my [inaudible].
Let me get it.
Got it. I wanted to ask you to do something.
Yeah, something I haven't done since my wife died. Oh,
okay.
And do you want to do the Santa and Mrs. Claus workshops like obsessed with
Christmas. It's the most wonderful time of the year.
It was like the lights, the cookies family.
But don't you have any other interests? What were you asking me?
You don't have to do the workshop thing on her first band. No,
that's not what I want. Let's keep that in mind.
Oh my God. Carol evil. Never guess what Nick asked me to do?
No, but I should put one in my purse just in case.
He asked me to go to his company's Christmas party.
Like he's totally into Christmas. Now. He tells me booked all week,
making that snow for his daughter, Noelle,
what's going on?
Hey, shouldn't you be outside? And I can see you're seeing another woman.
Are you just using me to make snow and holiday cheer for your daughter? No.
Holly, no.
I hired you to make it snow because there's absolutely no way you make money.
There are machines out there that they're doing exactly the same thing you were
doing. Fashion is not trying to change the subject. There's a woman in there.
Yeah, but that woman,
Holly dogs
I'll be so easily cleared up. If she would let me explain.
Sorry, Holly. I guess I'll just be all on for Christmas after all.
I'll be here. I know what happened.
You can't just walk in Holly.
I know we just met earlier today,
but I'm starting to think I can spend the rest of my life with you then.
Why did you hug another woman? Holly? That woman was my sister.
Your sister? Yes. My sister.
I don't know Nick. This is an ad enough.
If she's your sister then why is she so hot? Good genes. I suppose.
Gosh, Nick, I'm so sorry for the misunderstanding. So cookie. Oh,
now it's my time to be mad with you because this doesn't work.
If you don't trust me, what is it all I do trust you,
Holly. You're the one I want.
I'm not even sad anymore that my wife was murdered on Christmas and they never
found the killer because he brought me to you
mysterious ways.
Oh my
it's snowing. But I'm in here.
[inaudible] counting my Christmas party with me. I do. I will come with you.
Let me go change
almost ready.
[inaudible] watch killer Christmas.
This December on lifetime television for women.
[inaudible].